look what i'm doing right now i'm trying
to figure out how to bring value to my
community
oh [ __ ] i might have 20 minutes right
now let me tweet out
and put an instagram story of a link to
do free q a and then leave
and hope that when i'm answering
jennifer's question sean connelly
or marlon avery or dave j or right or
cisco or austin
like that is going to get some value
from it because maybe this time it hit
different
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
morning everyone what's good what's good
uh thanks for joining just wanted to do
some random q a
just wanted to wish everybody a good
weekend uh as i get into my mindset
of uh an hour and 15 minutes before the
jets play the chiefs which
should put me into a three-hour angry
session so i figure let me get 15
minutes of some happiness and
it's great to see a lot of smiling faces
i hope everyone's well uh dustin you can
just
unmute someone and uh let's get right
into some q a
i'm gonna go with ken oh crap
come on
hello hello hey what's up gary
what's good ken how you doing i'm really
well
dustin you pick somebody without a video
he
he's the first person that raised his
hands
ken what's good well no don't unum
oh i didn't do that oh he did it hold on
let's go and meet again
unless he dropped off hello ken what's
good
yeah what's up man hey get that video
going dustin hold on
that's on you bro what yeah here hold on
it's on you ken
why isn't he doing that it should set a
pop-up
there we go there we go ken how are you
doing good man what's good where are you
from
oh man i'm from st louis missouri
originally i'm up in minneapolis right
now though
that's what's up how can i help you man
so really for me
i mean obviously a lot of questions but
first i just want to say thank you for
everything you do for everybody
i appreciate that second man um just
looking to grow a business right now
me and a partner um and our big thing
right now is we know we can't do it
alone
so my big thing right now is trying to
figure out
when's the right time to really bring on
people
bring on build yeah like i mean that's
the thing
trying to you know differentiate
employees versus
interns volunteers you know all that so
i kind of
yes that strategy as soon as you can
afford it
yeah you know like if you've got no
money yet right now
you're really just trying to find
friends relatives acquaintances
that might just want to learn from the
process you know what i mean
right like when i started vaynermedia
you know
the first four or five people were aj's
friends from high school in college on
some real rugged entre
like intern you know like like
we we borrowed somebody's conference
room we
you know i was tapping into like the
little savings i had to like do
internship but mainly i was trying to
find a first client to pay for
everything
so the question is most people try to
but here's the biggest mistake kim
people try to build businesses so they
can make money from it
and the most important part of the first
five years is putting all the money back
in
it so when i answer your question when
to bring people on the second you can
right yeah right
simple is that no people are fancy when
they don't have
anything too the thing i think people
struggle with the beginning
because they're ideological versus
versus
reality based like if you have no money
you and your partner
then you're not hiring [ __ ] so you need
to basically just literally go to your
phone
start with the letter a and with the
letter z and literally text everybody
you know and say
yo do you want to help us on this thing
this is what we're popping off like
you have some side hours maybe we can
hire you eventually sorry we don't have
dollars now but i'll be there
you know sometimes people feel guilty
for that my big thing is you have your
whole life to pay back that person if it
doesn't work out so if somebody works
for you
for free for three months and it fails
and you quit then you hit up
k daily who i see on here or or will
center you say yo
sorry that it didn't pop off but i'm
here for you
you know you did right by me it didn't
work but
you know if i could ever be a help to
you like people are people are
ideological
ideology driven instead of practical
driven
the answer is as soon as possible all
right but
let's go appreciate you take care
you too
i see a lot of people in the chat let's
do old school too many youngsters in
here you probably don't even know what
asl means oh my gosh
all right who's up justin what's going
on
jennifer's on good oh my god i'm like
in chalk like oh my god hi jennifer
hi daddy hi oh my god um
um okay um
so i started this year being a designer
for um small like small businesses and
coaches
and and i have a couple of clients but
you know when
you say or people say oh nature down or
go
i don't know how to knit you down like i
don't know how to be specific enough
like
to capture their attention like if i
want to help
wellness coaches like how do i find them
how do i attract them or i i mean i i
think i just have to do
my content like to do my graphics or my
websites or whatever i create
that's the way i think well i don't know
if i'm doing it right
well what are you trying to accomplish
what do you want them to do
well ideally i i'm looking to grow my
followers so i can get more visibility
and people who want to get more how
often do you decide
yep how often do you post um
i was posting like every day until i
realized i was probably killing my
own traffic so i started posting now
like every two days
one time every two days yeah
i'm not a big fan of that no no
when you when you said you were
realizing you were killing your traffic
are you saying that you thought
that because you were posting every day
the algorithm wasn't giving as much
awareness
to the posts yes
yeah on instagram yes
that's the reason all of you are not
getting as many
views per your instagram posts are not
because you're posting too often
it's because most more people are
running ads on the platform
and it's now hit the maturity point
where everybody's views are about to go
down
and so even in reels and even in reals
jennifer the whole game is supply and
demand of content
and what everybody's making and some
people are now spending more time on
tick tock
some people are because of the because
of the
uh presidential election or feeling
anxiety or spending less time on
instagram
jerry i see you flexing your cards relax
baby so you know why uh
while everyone's you know it's just
supply and demand
you should be posting three times a day
three times a day that's right because
think about it if you get 500 views on
your post
if you how many posts were you
accustomed to getting
and then what did it go to that made you
go every other day
um because um i wasn't like reaching
it i was probably i'm only a 1200
so under 1200 so i was getting like
maybe like
20 likes or i don't know like 100 views
and
stories and and then suddenly it's like
10 10 likes or five likes and 50
views in a story so it's like and so you
started posting every other day
so that you would get back to the same
amount of numbers because that
one post would sit there for a longer
period of time and get that number
correct yeah jennifer that is literally
the single biggest mistake people make
on social media the number one mistake
your self-esteem is wrapped up in
hitting a number
instead of realizing that you have to
put out pieces of content
to build awareness think about this if
you post three times a day
and they all get 10 now yeah
30 instead of once every two days for 20
and that means every two days you get 60
instead of 20.
well how do you go about like creating
like good content
three times a day by being good
if you're not good enough to produce
good content three times a day
you're not going to build a business
anyway yeah yeah
by challenging yourself by coming up
with ideas by not being scared
by showing different parts of your life
by doing everything i [ __ ] talk about
every day
yeah because i was kind of like doing
educational but at the same time
inspirational but i was told by coaches
like oh no don't try to be
everything because they were like don't
try to be
everything don't try to be every day be
everything that
jennifer are you paying these coaches um
one i did did it work
and well no no well no listen to me
jennifer
put out content watch my [ __ ] for free
follow it
stop being insecure start overthinking
people are literally
seeing my content for free but would
rather
pay somebody money who's had less
success
because of insecurity yeah
but i think that's the key because i've
been insecure like why is it not working
everything that i'm creating so i come
down
because you're impatient i've produced
content for 11 hours a day for three
years before anybody cared
did you do that no okay
well there's one reason maybe the other
reason is because you're overthinking
your [ __ ]
and not putting out your truth
yeah yesterday a good piece of content
is what your favorite halloween candy is
somebody might just think that you're
human and that's good everyone here
got all these beautiful faces
overthinking [ __ ]
overthinking [ __ ] this is a volume game
yeah there's no right
right for you at that exact second
yeah yeah just scared like with the
instagram with algorithm and everything
that is like what you do and you spam it
you know so it's like the feeling that
you get
jennifer you're not spamming nobody's
seeing your [ __ ] you just told me you
stopped when less people saw it now
you're telling me you're spamming that's
a [ __ ] contradiction
yeah yeah i just i feel like if i post
too
too often people's gonna be like okay
that's enough
is this working more people will be two
days more people gonna see you
and and think about and think about
putting out stuff for them look what i'm
doing right now
yeah yeah look what i'm doing right now
look what i'm doing right now
i'm trying to figure out how to bring
value to my community oh [ __ ] i might
have 20 minutes right now
let me tweet out and put an instagram
story of a link to do free q a and then
leave
and hope that when i'm answering
jennifer's question sean connelly
or marlin avery or dave j or right or
cisco or austin
like that is going to get some value
from it because maybe this time it hit
different
yeah everybody's making everybody's
making content for themselves
you're trying to make content so it
leads to customers
yeah when you yeah to create a community
as well yeah
no no not not build a community only
only the only way you're gonna sell
something eventually is if you actually
build a community the only way you can
build a community is bring value to
others
everybody's so selfish that's why it
doesn't work
by the way it's okay to be selfish i
have no
literally do not look down on anyone
who's trying to build something for
themselves
but when you're trying to build
something for yourself there's somebody
on the other side of this
yeah they're not here to you're not here
to
pay money to everybody else
you're here to get value for you you're
going to pay
something that brings you go watch a
movie that you want to watch
you go buy a bottle of wine or a pair of
sneakers or
that you want to drink that you want to
wear
everyone's just thinking about what
they're what they're going to get for it
and then they then they get spooked
about the algorithm
the algorithm is not your problem your
problem is your mindset if you're
bringing value to people
if you're thinking this is going to lead
to a sale it's already over before you
started
i don't give a [ __ ] about the algorithm
awesome good luck jennifer
thank you thank you of course
whoever you want dust one second one
second
i'm gonna put on nicholas bianchi
here's your god damn it
nicholas you are on hey gary
what's good brother so i'm
15 and i've been trying to get really
hardcore into basketball cards
okay and i've collected some few cards
like i have these like
luca rookies and michael porter i'm
listening and
and so like i'm wondering like what
should i be trying to invest
on and like when should i think about
like selling if i were to try and do
that
i mean i'm about to buy a lot of
basketball cards right now because
they're dipping because it's the off
season
and i think the time to sell in the way
that you're buying which is short term
flipping is when they go off in the
first couple weeks when the hype comes
back
i mean you've already learned nicholas
how markets work you saw how much luca
was going for
when he was killing in the playoffs and
you see that it's half as much now right
yeah so what you want to do is you want
to strike on emotion when nobody's
paying attention that's when you're
buying
and when the season comes back and they
go off when luca drops 61
that's going to be a high moment that's
when you want to move you want to move
when it's hype
you want to buy when no one's no one's
paying attention
all right and then so like for like
rookies coming in
should i buy them the rookies like right
when they're like drafted
or should i wait until they've played of
it it depends on how you want to play it
there's always a lot of hype of the
unknown
i for example have bought zero jammer
ant and zero zion
still to the second zero
but that's how i'm playing i want to see
them play a little bit more so i can
decide who they are
but there was plenty of money to be made
on john tyler hero
i'm just not gambling as much as
everybody else i'm playing a little bit
longer
so but you might love someone you might
just want to you know like
follow mello ball you know what i mean
yeah that hype train
so that's more like how you want to do
it you know
yeah keep learning the biggest things
at 15 nicholas learning supply and
demand how to market a card
why markets go up why markets go down
the reason i love this for a lot of kids
is that's where i learned so much which
now
helps me 30 years later you're going to
learn a lot of stuff along the way
losing money at this age is a great
learning tool
and i have one more question as a fellow
jets fan
are you more on the sam darnold train or
trevor lawrence
sam darnold i would rather trade um
look at the jets offense le'veon bell's
had two runs over 16 yards
already in six carries with the chiefs
and have done with us yeah
football is the ultimate team sport i
think sam can play and i think if we
have the number one pick
we're gonna get five or six massive top
100 picks
probably three number ones two number
twos and i think we can build a whole
franchise around that and i think sam
can play
peace thank you next you got it brother
dustin let's move it
chairwoman stephanie
hello how are you i'm well how are you
i'm good um i'm like having trouble with
sales
um my products are good like i always
get good reviews but
i get the traffic and i don't get the
sales like this week
this past week i got over like 1.5
k um people that visited my site what
are you selling
i sell natural hair care and skincare
products are you getting good traffic
are you getting targeted traffic
i'm not really even sure like i did a
lot of referrals
i could go i get a lot of referrals um
and then like i get well most of them
are coming from instagram
and are you i mean there's two reasons
why
traffic doesn't convert it's bad traffic
right it's not your target audience at
the
product your website there's actually
there's b your website doesn't do a good
job
creating confidence or conversion and
three
there's the reality that your product
isn't
priced well and isn't interesting as a
product
okay what so i think
i think um have you have you made sales
yeah i have um like before covet hit
like around that time
i made a lot of sales and then like i
believe like two months later they like
declined
and i'm getting like my regular people
that always buy
but i'm trying to figure out ways to
actually um
get out there i think one of the things
that i would do if i were you is i would
call everybody i would do these two
things i would call
literally email and set up a call with
everybody who
has bought something from you and asked
them why they bought
and then i would make videos on your
instagram right now
asking people have they gone to your
website and why
did they buy and ask them to comment
okay consumers always have the answers
okay all right thank you you're welcome
steph
let's keep moving but we just told
stephanie is that something a lot of you
have to ask more you have to ask
why more you have to ask the audience
like
for real
uh sean connelly oh my god
hey gary what's good sean how you doing
i'm well man how are you i'm really good
i i just want to tell you first like
thank you so much for everything you do
it's amazing thank you brother um so i'm
an aspiring singer
and like the thing about me is i like i
like comedy
so i have a parody page with my friend
and then
i have my own channel and i'm trying to
grow both
okay but like i don't know how to
balance the two if that makes sense
by not judging yourself okay
i'm just like literally
you want one more every day one day you
want this one more
the next day you want that one more for
90 days i was super hot building my
dad's wine text for him
because i wanted to and i wanted to help
him and the next day i changed my mind
and focused on sports cards
and then as a lot of people know i
haven't said a thing about sports cards
for five weeks because
right now i'm focused on vayner x you're
just you're judging yourself
you don't need to know which one you
want more you want them both and every
day
it's like [ __ ] eating cereal bro
sometimes you want lucky charms
sometimes you want [ __ ]
you know captain crunch everyone [ __ ]
overthinks this [ __ ] shawn
that's true like what like like what you
want to both
yeah i wanted to say something else too
um so i've been dealing with like a lot
lately with corona i'm sure like
of course you know like there's just a
lot of stress and stuff yep and
like my my dad's been going through a
lot of hard times you know
um he's been he's been battling uh
alcohol abuse
and like it's just like i feel
suffocated sometimes
by like the negativity and like
trying not to like get emotional about
this but like
it's just hard to like continue to put
out the stuff that i want to do
when like i see him in such a pace
place of pain and like suffering
i understand that a couple things you
know
there's two ways it's kind of almost
similar to the last part
of like having two different accounts
it's okay
for three days for you to be
just so concerned about your dad and not
have the energy to go do
and it's equally okay on thursday of
that week to pump out [ __ ] like crazy
like it's
like everything's okay like everything's
ok like every feeling is allowed
you're allowed to fight through and
choose to see optimism
you're also allowed to have compassion
and sympathy for your dad
and have remorse and some sadness people
over judge themselves sean when i look
at everybody here right now and i'm
clicking through
the you know all all the faces here
i i don't know i will say this until the
day i die
i don't understand why people judge
things
in such short periods of time
[Music]
this too it's just like i just recently
dropped out of school
and like that too kind of added into his
stress
so it's just like these factors
it's like i'm in my own head in a way
you know like every single person in
this video is in their own head
like every we're all in our own head
that's
that's where life is actually lived the
body's just the [ __ ] manifestation of
what's going on in your head
yeah like like
covet is exposed so much
of course you're in your head that's
good what you need to do
is take a breath
yeah you're a kid yeah your dad's
ideology of you gonna be okay
because a school is gonna work itself
out
yeah thank you yeah that means a lot do
you know what i mean
yeah like it just take a breath like
we're so fortunate to be alive like
do you know how anxious half the country
is going to be in two days in two days
half our entire country on one side or
the other is going to be on complete
tilt
for weeks in deep anxiety one way or the
other
like it's okay life it happens
yeah you know like you have to stop
judging yourself
you've got 80 more years of life sean
80.
yeah it's just like i want my dad you
know to be good i don't want to be
selfish you know like i don't want to
get well then then then you know then
pound your dad with positivity i know
but that's the thing like
that's the reason i feel like he's in
this place is that his parents kind of
instilled this negative mindset
my dad too my dad's mom instilled
nothing but negativity into him i've
been spending
30 years pounding positivity into my
dad's brain
okay you ca i mean life is very simple
everyone
you can either dwell about the
circumstance or you can go on the
offense
you can dwell like i do in the micro at
times about what my grandma did to my
dad
or you could go on the offense like i do
99
of the time you just got to make sure
that that ratio is in a healthy place
yeah there is no time machine you can't
go back into time
and correct how your grandparents
you know parented your dad what you need
to do is
you need to separate from your dad when
he's dragging you down and put
positivity in your ears
and then when you're filled up you need
to go back on the offense on your dad
and try to pound it into him
and then when you're drained and he
starts dragging you down you need to go
back to the well of positivity and put
in your ears
that's all i'm basically doing for the
world all i'm basically doing
every day sean is putting out practical
and positive content
to allow people to fill up so that they
can go back into their real lives
and do something with it that's all i'm
really doing
i'm basically doing for this world what
i did for my dad
because there is nothing else i don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody says right now
everything is how you're going to look
at it
yeah that's life life is how
you see it
period yeah you have to surround
yourself with positivity
so that you can be full and good so that
you can go and
give love to somebody you love like your
dad and then you dump out some of that
positivity
and you come back to i mean it's just
[ __ ] that's the game
yeah i mean that's yeah i'm gonna focus
on that it's just
that's the only practical thing you can
focus on yeah
you can't rewire your dad's dna in
upbringing
you could just pound him with facts of
positivity
perspective encourage him to take
therapy all those things
he is yeah he's in the process he's just
like it's a healing phase so it's just
obviously he's having withdrawal and all
this colder things
so it's just like really hard for me to
look you know see him go through this
stuff of course you love him i get it i
lived it
i live it but you just have you have no
choice
everything's hard
i mean like you could have had your arm
chopped off
with a lawnmower accident like some kid
i know you could have
yeah you could have gotten hit by a
[ __ ] tree you could have
you could have like you could have
coveted could have not happened
and you might have been in a car instead
of in a house
because the world was normal and you
might have got into a car accident died
that could have happened
your dad could have died nine years ago
of cancer that could have happened
i i you know i think people people get
into this mindset like they have it so
bad
they have no context of the world
there's people ages in america let alone
the rest of the world right now
we have no gratitude you have to use
gratitude as your offset for your
concerns
okay you know what i mean yeah no i know
what you mean
i totally understand
all right good luck do you um
gary do you think i could give you my
like handle or
something to like help me or is that
i don't want to seem like like i don't
know
because like my content honestly has not
been hitting
and i don't know what i'm doing wrong
what you're doing wrong is you're not
trying new [ __ ]
and i don't want to give you false hit
of a death like
no okay i understand that yeah i know
you say that i knew you didn't
but in a good way right like i'm trying
to come out with love like
what you need to do is try different
[ __ ] yeah
yeah okay and sean i said to that you're
welcome brother what i said earlier
really matters man
i'm saying this because i don't have to
bounce in a minute everyone and you know
i'm gonna try to do this a lot more
often random q a's and i hope that
people realize like
other people's questions help you too
and i hope you got some value out of
this sean what i said earlier
is the truth like the number one reason
everybody here is here right now on this
zoom
is the number one reason 99 of people
here are not getting what they want
let me explain 99
of people are here right now because i
bring them value
i bring you value
insights inspiration uh a different look
at something
clarity i'm you think i'm funny i don't
[ __ ] know like
you know like i bring you value that's
why you right now have chosen to give
this time
um most people on here are trying to get
the same
but are trying to take not give
it's not complicated share your story
share your dark secrets that might help
somebody
share a tip like like people are really
struggling to give
everyone here is so worried about how to
get their content
to bring them what they want they forget
that
the audience on the other side is the
whole punch line
i'm obsessed literally think about the
meta of this
i realized i had a little bit of time
and i'm like you know what i know
tensions are high because the election
i know it's like rainy i'm in a lot of
places i'm like i'm like
why don't i just give some good value
for 20 30 minutes like that'll be nice
that'll be good like i got plenty of
[ __ ] i need
i need you know i i got plenty of [ __ ]
to do during this time but like how do i
bring value
shout out to jaden leon looks like
trevor lawrence and his gesture got me
excited
um anyway please bring value
i will thank you so much gary you're
welcome brother dustin thanks for this
love everybody hope you have a good day
have a good sunday
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video if uh
if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out